hello and thanks for joining me today
my name is jeff privette i am a deputy
director with pima county wastewater
and i'm also have extensive background
in molecular and atomic spectroscopy
for the past three years the united
states epa contracted with the
university of arizona the denton
research group and myself
to help develop standard protocols for
the preparation sampling and analysis of
microplastics the title of my talk is
the need for standardized monitoring
methodologies and microplastics analysis
and i hope you find some information
covered of value and feel free to reach
out to me at the end with any questions
you may have we've all seen photographs
similar to the one depicted in this
slide
with lots of plastics contamination
plastic bottles styrofoam
floating on the edges of riverbanks in
the oceans we face a worldwide challenge
and environmental dilemma in regards to
plastics recycling and disposal
when we see images like this we often
think of third world or developing
countries
however
we see problems like this
everywhere the photo on the left this is
one of the well-known uh pacific geyers
it's just a massive heap of floating
material styrofoam plastics all that
type of material we typically see
pollution like this at the macro level
with full-size plastic bottles and just
discarded debris
this 20 20 new york times article kind
of brings it home a little closer
you'll see a large metropolitan facility
in the background with tons of floating
debris all along the shores and beach
lines
and the article indicates there's nearly
16 million tons below the surface that
we don't see
when we discuss microplastics research
we're typically talking
fragments of these plastic bottles and
and waste debris
on the order of one micron to five
thousand microns or five millimeters
anything smaller than one micron would
be considered nanoplastics anything
larger than that well that's macro scale
stuff you can visually see with your
eyes
and this 2020 article suggests that the
pollution may be far worse than
previously thought even double that
when epa contracted us for this work
there were five goals in mind for astm
procedure positive polymer
identification
quantification of the number of
particles in a sample
the size distribution of particles in a
sample and preferably the shapes
differentiating fibers versus
breakdown products of plastics and
preferably a total mass content
the image on the left
is from january 2021
and it implicates clothes washing is a
major source of microplastics
contamination
and when you think about it
it's probably accurate
consider for a moment the amount of
dryer lint that we all pull out of our
regular clothes washing dryers
it's usually comprised of human hair
lots of cotton fibers but also lots of
synthetic fibers too
when you consider the amount of athletic
clothing that we all enjoy
whether it's under armour gear dry fit
type anti-sweat workout gear even very
common yoga pants we tend to see lots of
these synthetic fibers
making its way into our clothing styles
in a deviation away from cotton we tend
to notice all that drier lint because
our dryer has a lint screen
but equal amount of those fragments also
come out in the wash and are discharged
into public sewers because there's not a
screen on the wash we don't see it
the image on the left was from an
article that came out just six months
ago in july of twenty twenty
implicating the ocean plastics could
triple by twenty forty the number of
plastics could outnumber fish in the
oceans by 2050.
this is a very bold statement could it
be true and could it ever be verified
these are just some of the environmental
implications that we see
in headlines worldwide
this 2018 article first chronicled the
detection of microplastics and human
stools
from a human health perspective these
are just one of many articles depicting
the severe health effects and this
article was followed up one week later
by a more skepticism type article that
says
there's a lack of analytical methods and
valid studies corroborate any kind of
health clinical damage from these
microplastics
but that doesn't stop sensational
headlines
they call microplastics an emerging
health crisis we've all heard of
emerging contaminants well they're
considering microplastics an urgent
emerging health crisis with many studies
indicating that they find plastic
particles in bottled beverages
even purified water processed foods and
many seafoods with 93 of all bottled
water samples containing microplastics
even more alarming our studies
suggesting organ toxicity and impending
health crisis
with toxicity to the brain liver lungs
and intestinal tracts from ingesting
microplastics this 2019 usa today
article chronicles a study of the
university of newcastle australia
that indicates that the average human on
the planet consumes over 2 000 pieces of
plastic every week
or 21 grams a month that's the
equivalent of eating 52 credit cards per
year so these headlines seem to indicate
that there's an impending public health
crisis through the ingestion of these
plastic particles
and in this study october of 2020
indicates they detected high levels of
microplastics leaking from baby bottles
used for formula preparation
this article chronicles over 16 million
microplastics with trillions of even
smaller nanoplastics per liter
which
makes me wonder who is making these
bottles and is there any quality control
criteria
just last month january 2021 was this
article indicating that plastic
pollution is showing up everywhere
scientists look
well if it's showing up everywhere it's
either ubiquitous and we have massive
widespread contamination worldwide or
could it be
that there's an error in our data in our
method of analysis those are key
questions to be considered
which brings me back to this 2019
article
this study reviewed
over 50 publications dealing with the
analysis of microplastics and they
didn't choose
complicated matrices like sewage or fish
tissues this was done on fresh water and
drinking water samples some of the
cleanest sample matrices one would think
they could encounter
in the review of these 50 research
articles
the conclusion was contamination is
unavoidable
in only 32 of the 50 studies were
procedural blanks analyzed
and then only
three of the 50 samples were procedural
spikes used this lack of data integrity
and method validation calls into
question some of the results
i remember early on in my graduate
career with bonner denton he expressed
this phrase often
bad data is worse than no data at all it
impedes your decision-making abilities
it exacerbates the problem you're
attempting to study
it can negatively impact your reputation
and it could have severe cost
implications
which brings us to the current state of
our research effort
chronicled over the last three years in
total we chose these 13 analytical
methods for the basis of our study
one because
being spectroscopist by nature
these ftir and raman spectroscopy
methods allowed for positive
identification against known libraries
of compounds
they also allowed for visual
identification of particles which aided
in quantification now there are some
research groups out there that prefer gc
pyrolysis but that's a destructive
technique
which while it does positively identify
the polymer type it gives you a total
mass number
uh it it's a destructive technique and
so you lose out all the finer aspects as
far as the number of particles and the
size distribution of particles
in particular
consider the cost of these different
analytical methods they range in price
wildly from two hundred and twenty
dollars a sample to over four thousand
dollars for a sample
this is due to the amount of time
required to prepare the sample for
analysis and also the uh and also the
length of time for analysis on the
equipment
if you're using traditional micro ftir
or micro raman using a rastering type
stage
your analysis times could be multiple
days
if you're using a focal plane array
detector your analysis times can easily
be 24 hours or greater
so starting at the beginning
with sample collection
you'll see that most sample collection
techniques relied on two methodologies
either sieving of a sample
allowing you to get specific size
fractions or filtering a sample
i prefer sieving sieving you can
purchase sieves with different
poor diameters
whereas filters tend to often clog and
be problematic
and the sieves can be stacked from
larger diameter down to smaller diameter
allowing to collect specific fragments
or particle size and this may be very
beneficial to some of these bottled
water
distributions in determining where in
the process are the particles coming are
they coming from the actual blow
injection of the bottles are they coming
from the screw on lids or is there
delamination of the polymeric membranes
in the ro systems
there was also considerable
variation in the sample size used for
each of these studies
collecting a representative sample is
absolutely necessary
especially when trying to extrapolate
and quantify for larger operations
for example if you're trying to
characterize
the discharge from a
let's say a 20 million gallon a day
wastewater treatment facility and the
amount of polymers that are discharged
the environment you want to capture the
entire diurnal pattern throughout the
day so a 24-hour composite is probably
the best route
and you'll see that some of these
studies used as small as 700 mils to
just over a liter
now here's the problem if you're using
such a small sample volume
and you do have natural contamination
either in your sample collection or your
sample preparation or your sample
preparation is so vigorous that it
breaks down particles into multiple
particle components
when you try to extrapolate that
one liter to a 20 million gallon you're
going to vastly overestimate the number
of particles so there's a definitely a
need for large volumes for
representative consistency
because we are spectroscopists we chose
to stick with the
the analytical methods typically
involved around micro ftir micro ramen
but there was one that looked at
stereoscopic visual identification
these visual methods of identification
are grossly
inaccurate they're unable to distinguish
one plastic polymer from another
we've even seen some where they use a
hot pin to touch the plastic particle
and see if it melts if it does well then
it's confirmed plastics but you know
really that's that has all the
scientific integrity of a coin toss and
should be discarded we need these
methods that we can compare the plastics
against a known library
and this is where gc mass spectroscopy
works as well but then you lose the
value of sample particle size and number
distribution
so the following slides
depict the questions that epa posed of
us in developing this method our goal
was to add greater analytical robustness
and greater data integrity
so in order for a method to be robust
we need standardization and
reproducibility that reproducibility has
to occur at the sample collection sample
preparation and throughout sample
analysis
i'm assuming most of the people
listening are laboratory personnel
and therefore you're very accustomed to
using sop standard operating procedures
for
sample collection preparation and
analysis
and that's what we're trying to
establish here reproducible methods that
would
tender the same type of results
regardless of which lab or who was doing
the
preparation and analysis
so the primary goal for sample
collection is one that it's
straightforward it's simple to follow
and it's reproducive as possible
these were the goals for any analytical
sampling methodology
and because we were using wastewater
matrices
epa selected us because we're a
wastewater utility and they wanted to
start with one of the more difficult
sample preparation and difficult
matrices available if it would work in
wastewater
then it was undoubtedly going to work in
surface waters and drinking water
samples
and so
the cartoon on the left depicts some of
the necessary components you'll need to
do this
because most the tankage in a wastewater
treatment plant are below grade you're
going to need a pump
capable of pumping with considerable
head 10 to 20 feet
the flow rate we selected was three
gallons per minute that was selected so
as not to overwhelm the sieve stack now
if you're doing influent you're probably
going to have a lot of debris and
cellulose materials lots of toilet paper
and influence and they'll tend to clog
up the sieve stack and so we do a
stacked set of sieves that we can pull
out particular fractions 300 micron
fraction 100 micron fractions if you're
going over three gallons a minute
depending on how dirty the insulin is
you can quickly overwhelm those sieves
so having flow control over the volume
is definitely necessary we chose
stainless steel transfer tubing for
everything we didn't want nylon ptfe or
any type of materials that could uh
possibly add contaminants to our sample
and be miscounted
a programmable timer now
at three gallons per minute in one of
our influence samples will probably bind
up and clog that screen mesh in about
three hours
and so i would typically set my timer
for two and a half hour intervals we'd
go out collect the material from the
sieve
re-initiate the pump for another two and
a half hours and we would do that over a
24-hour period so we're getting a
composite sample over a 24-hour period
sieve stacks you can get in various uh
porosity diameters
and then some type of a
collection sieve here it's showing a
plastic bucket but we took a regular uh
aluminum bucket drilled holes in the
bottom that contained all the sieves in
it
one other key feature that you should
consider is an inline flow meter inline
flow meter will help you dial in the
flow control of the volume going to the
sieves
that'll avoid overburdening them but
also a flow controller that also
is a totalizer and records total volume
process
that's very handy and so the ideal
features would be something that's easy
to set up and calibrate something allows
flow control
something that records total volume
you can use peristaltic or or
submersible pumps
and fractionating sieves
so the photograph on the left is of a
typical influence sample you'll see
large debris
large mat largely toilet paper that's
binding on the filter while the one on
the right that's a much finer mesh
that's probably about a 25 micron sieve
and it's free of debris still has some
shallows material but a lot of algal
material thing a lot of our tanks are
open exposed daylight so we get a lot of
algal buildup in there and that's what
you see on the sieve itself
so the real challenge comes in the
sample preparation and again
the sop that we're trying to develop
needs to be easy to replicate
needs to address interferences
and minimize the loss of particles one
item not on here is minimize the
addition of particles if you have an
aggressive sample preparation scheme
and it's overly aggressive even just
stirring the sample overly aggressive
one particle could break into two three
multiple particles and then numerically
you're over counting those particles so
we want to keep that in mind as well
so one of the test methods i didn't
highlight on the 13 methods that we
evaluated was this one by loader in
2017.
it's the universal enzymatic
purification protocol
this is a very elegant protocol because
it addresses a variety of of
interference that one may encounter
especially in wastewater matrices
it addresses proteins fats oils and
greases
toilet paper cellulose
has a wet peroxide oxidation
chitinase that
that is a lot of the you're going to see
bug fragments that are in sewage
as well so we chose it based on these
three key characteristics
and in a slightly different order almost
all the methodologies we encountered use
some form of wet oxidation with peroxide
and a few of them used
density separations using either zinc
chloride or a calcium chloride
and when dealing with wastewater
cellulose is a is a huge bird it's
probably 90 95 of the problem that
you're trying to address is the
interference from cellulose and so
these three steps we took and we chose
to improve upon them because looking at
here look at the amount of time it was
required to do this analysis it ranged
from
well over a week up to 15 days to
prepare early steps
keep in mind each one of these steps
you're adding something to the sample
it's exposed to your lab environment so
if contamination is ubiquitous if it's
everywhere you're going to contaminate
that sample at every step along the way
and so we chose these three steps
outlined in red
but going away from the enzymatic
protocol we needed faster turnaround
time and to avoid contamination to make
this a viable test for most laboratories
and we also chose to implement some type
of protocol to validate our study so we
had method spikes included as well so
this was the samples that we analyzed
using the loader protocol with the
enzymatic
buffers
and
you'll see there is some cellulosic
debris still present in the sample but
it's
probably 99 removed from what it was in
the original wastewater sample you see
these large particles these were
obviously an influence sample and we
spiked them with two different types of
polymers
i've highlighted those here the red
polyethylene polymers these were 700 or
70 excuse me 70 to 120 microns
and the larger particles were another
polypropylene that was in the 200 micron
range in size and so we spiked with two
different type of polymers
and when you visually look at them under
a microscope like this if the particles
are broken then you can
it leads to overestimation but it tells
you that your
preparation technique is probably too
aggressive
and if you don't recover your particles
you're probably
assured that you're losing material
throughout your process as well and so
this was very valuable for us
our final method selection uses those
three key features that we found common
to most analytical methods but in a
slightly different order we chose as our
first stage to do the wet oxidation
almost 90 percent of the research
articles use some form of wet oxidation
and we find that extremely valuable
because
for one it oxidizes a lot of the organic
matter and the easily oxidizable carbon
and so it's a form of disinfecting the
sample and protecting the laboratory
staff
before moving forward
we do this with a fenton reagent which
is a 30 peroxide with an iron catalyst
this will destroy pathogens it oxidizes
the organic matter in the sample
rendering it much cleaner especially in
those effluent samples where you have a
lot of algal
material
and it also releases materials from the
plastic surface
so one of the things that epa was
concerned about was the amount of
biofilm and co-contaminants that may be
deposited on a sample particle plastic
particle
and so when you think of that we
commonly see
pcbs and other type of materials that
are bound to plastics and if these are
in an ocean or in a lake or a waterway
the aquatic species will then come along
eat those plastics ingest those coke
contaminants as well and so that's why
it's critical for us to know the shape
and size of the particle to estimate how
much coke contaminants are on there as
well and the fenton region releases that
biofilm and those contaminants from the
plastic surface
the next step was the use of a
schweizer's region
in place of the cellulase digestion
in the loader method they used a
cellulase digestion which proved quite
effective but it was very timely often
required up to three days to remove
toilet uh the cellulose
toilet paper from the influence samples
and so schweizer's reagent is actually a
copper ammonia complex and it's almost
like
something a magician you would use you
add the schweizer's reagent to the
sample it instantly
breaks down the cellulose and allows us
to then take that same sample run it
through the corresponding sieve and the
cellulose is gone we then extract those
particles right off the sieve a second
time it's a rapid reaction it eliminates
cellulose it greatly minimizes sample
preparation time and it avoids
contamination
the third
key step
was density separations throughout the
literature we'll see a lot of
laboratories using either a zinc
chloride or calcium chloride solution
uh at a concentration that makes it to a
density of 1.4 to 1.7 grams per mil
in effect the heavier inorganic type
material sinks to the bottom the
plastics float to the polymer plastic
polymers float to the top then those are
then skimmed off and
analyzed
one problem that we note with that
is you'll see a lot of those plastic
particles that float to the top want to
adhere to the edge of the container
which can be problematic
and so for our studies we chose to use a
centrifuge rather than
floating the material to the top and
i'll describe that briefly for you
so here's the way the procedure would
typically go and depending on the sample
matrices you're using all of these steps
may not be necessary
so this is the worst case scenario using
waste water influence we'll do a wet
peroxide with a fetan reagent for an
hour that's going to decontaminate the
sample and remove all the easily
oxidizable carbon and lift any biofilm
off of the plastic particles themselves
rendering them
much
a much cleaner surface for spectroscopy
analysis
we would then centrifuge that sample for
15 minutes
all the plastic particles are going to
become compacted in the pellet and we
decant off the excess liquid using a
micropipette
then if you're using waste water samples
we'd do a cellulose digestion with the
schweizer's reagent for five minutes
again centrifuge and decant and then
quench that with ammonium hydroxide five
minutes
this is in comparison to the multiple
day digestion that we saw with
the
loader using the
catalase enzymes
the next step is we use a tris buffer
and that tris buffer what that does
it
it helps keep the particles in solution
and from adhering to the plastic walls
of the container itself
and then we use a if you're still using
wastewater samples you may want to do a
simultaneous protease in light based
digestion obviously for
for
effluent samples surface water samples
or bottled water samples you're not
going to have proteins and fats in the
sample and so you can avoid that step
which is it's a 20-hour step but that's
because it has these enzymes that need
time to react and again you would then
centrifuge decant
wash it and be ready for analysis we
always suspend the plastic particles
finally in methanol and that is to keep
it from adhering to the walls of the
container keeps them in solution and
then when you plate the
particles out onto a microscope slide
you're able to the methanol will
evaporate and so now you have a clean
matrix that you can put in the
instrument
so essentially
it's a two-step process for most samples
one using the fenton reagent to
decontaminate the sample and clean it up
and then the second using a schweizer's
reagent for removing cellulose now again
you only need the schweizers if you're
dealing with
influence samples that have a lot of
cellulose material in there a lot of
toilet paper
and we typically do these although
they're pictured in beakers here on the
screen we typically do all of this
within a single conical tube and that
same tube is used throughout therefore
there's no transferring of solutions
from one beaker to another where you
could possibly encounter contamination
everything's done in a single vial so
add your reagent to the vial
shake it for the time interval
centrifuge it
open the vial put in your second reagent
shake it centrifuge it so we're trying
to minimize contamination throughout
this process
so this is a oversimplified cartoon
showing a micro centrifuge tube but it
would be the same for the larger 50 ml
tubes that we used and so
after centrifuging the final sample
all the materials compacted in the
pellet because we didn't use any density
separations
and then we use a micro pipette to
basically pull off all the liquid from
the sample getting as close to the
pellet as you can and you can do this
under a
stereo microscope as well so you make
sure you're not
pulling up any of the particles in the
pipette
and so once we've pulled out all the
material we add just a drop or two of
methanol we then remove the pellet plate
the pellet out on the microscope slide
this eliminates filtration sample loss
the cellulose is completely removed
preparation time is very short we can do
this in just a few hours taking a sample
from the initial raw sample collected
off the sieve to a sample that's ready
for analysis
all the sieve contents are now plated on
a single slide
and we have reference spike recoveries
that are near 100
and finally we get to the sample
analysis workflow
so regardless of what method we're using
whether it's
micro raman micro ftir
or
gc pyrolysis we want to be able to
positively identify the particles and
the way we do that is against a
reference library
quantification of particles you're not
going to be able to quantify the number
of particles using gc pyrolysis you will
get a total mass
of the particle content
but if you're using micro ftir or micro
raman you will be able to count the
individual particles they will also
allow a
particle size distribution which is
going to be
a beneficial feature
and provided you have a focal plane
array or some instrument that's able to
rapidly scan the slide the results
should be fast and reproducible
so after working with microrahmann
method for a good part of a year
we were able to obtain
agilent ldr 8700 as a chemical imaging
system that was originally designed for
pharmaceutical analysis
however it has demonstrated itself be
very beneficial for
particle analysis as well
so the first step is to take that slide
that we previously plated we insert it
into the instrument and the first thing
we select is the
relative sensitivity
we would
pull up a library the microplastics
library that we've assembled has common
components such as polyethylene
polypropylene
ldpe hdpe
teflon and other common rubbers and
different types of plastic polymers
we then select the sensitivity for this
slide this is influence sample so i've
only selected to analyze for particles
larger than 100 micron and smaller than
5000 micro now if we were looking at
effluent samples we may change this to
look at particles from
20 micron up to maybe 300 microns
this was material obtained on a 500
micron sieve
and
this area that's under analysis
this probably took it roughly an hour to
analyze
and it's
probably about 1 6 of the slide
and you'll see the number of particles
that were analyzed and identified on
this
here's the most important part
every particle that we've analyzed you
get an optical image
and then you get the infrared image
along with
the spectrum and the reference spectrum
overlaid
and you also get the benefit of the
diameter and area of the particle and
this is something that epa was very
interested in for establishing what the
co-contaminant
loading may be on these particles
and so these were a polystyrene particle
here you see the data
for that entire slide you see the number
count
and the number of particles that were
detected what percentage that they
represent of the total particles
identified
and for any particles that are
unidentified that are unknown you can
always go back and manually
analyze them with an ftir and maybe look
at against different libraries now this
is just the natural
microplastics library which you
typically see here we still have
cellulose on screen because we know
we're dealing with wastewater matrices
so we look for that but here's some
normal
sample analysis
and it tells you what the particle size
range was for each of those particles so
for this wastewater influent we'll see
that almost 95 of all of our particles
are in the 20 to 50 micron range with
the second tier being the 50 to 100
micron range
very valuable information we're able to
acquire
so thank you for your time today
here's my contact information if any of
you would like to get in touch with me
if you have any suggestions for
improvements please feel free to reach
out to me thank you
you